hey guys we start is gonna donate ensure
he invited us a which is also famous for
its chocolate marido she's not only
famous for its chocolate it's also
famous for the seven lakes
alright guys we are on the way to the
most beautiful viewpoint of body Russia
close to body russia called cerro
campanario it only takes about 20
minutes if you are in good shape and as
we are in good shape and will only take
us 25 minutes night vision mountain goat
kristin is making her way
that you guys were about to do our first
hike and for this one we chose the trek
to the throne adore from Pam Belinda
vamonos we hiked up to the refugio auto
mailing and we will camp out there to
put our outdoor gear to a proper test
before we hiked into more difficult
terrain and I think it's a good start to
come out next to a glacier it's rather
dollar there it is the turn on door and
here you can see what we started oh it's
really beautiful over there this is Pam
budino this is starting point ha there
is such a good high castle it took us
Omni for hours
we're almost there the last part was a
bit rocky and very steep but now we're
next to the glacier here it is the
glacier and there is our pokey oh and we
will camp next to that
good morning it was really cold tonight
but a good thing about the spotters you
get rewarded in the morning because the
sunrise here it's pretty cool
and we are back in pampa Linda enjoyable
hi Kristen yeah I was beautiful but it
was long about 40 kilometers and we can
still see the Toronto we just came from
it's back there in the clouds so we just
made it back in time so I would say just
an amazing high